you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads bites hello
to your friends and welcome back to the
game spot stage right here at e3 2016
I'm delighted to be joined by mr. Steve
males and grant Kirkhope of ukulele hey
great to have you wonderful to be here
yeah thank you so much to read as well
we're going to you have a great little
chat about this game and it's it's it's
great to see you guys here with like a
really like full demo of ukulele because
there is always these worries when when
you've Kickstarter's that you know we're
going to see this we're going to see it
we're gonna seem like five or six years
time and have you felt about the whole
process of these lately it's been
wonderful since since the Kickstarter
everything John the Kickstarter was
quite a quite short term so now we've
been able to work for a year kind of go
doc and get our heads down and work on
the game right people you can see people
on the phone oh I wonder what's
happening which is kind of a good thing
because we're like things to be a
surprise but we've expanded the team
from six to twenty people right and
we're all heads down and it's going
great yeah that got a whole like last
year's thing was just a kind of its not
smoking mirrors but bit of a little demo
thing we are kind of going it's so nice
to have something proper right oh now
you know if I'll be working very hard
you're never all very old Malcolm right
oh but also experience and I guess
that's a lot that's a good experience
yeah actual invested yes those are the
kind of bandidos was about quite a lot
these days it's not a bit more
importantly actually even with your
experience so we were you expecting the
kick started to be as successful as it
was no way absolutely not it's such a
wonderful time none of us will ever
forget that moment you know that that
number just kept climbing and climbing
we thought yeah we might get to a target
after him you know a week or so clear he
just we blitzed the target i think it
was 38 minutes and went on to be oh my
gosh I stove a kickstart for game and
globally one of the highest ever kinkos
for video to millions dollars in the
first 21 hours it's incredible I know we
were obviously like you press refresh
going there just so good there that we
thought was broken by the way thank the
fans forever cuz they they they'll play
tone it as a proper studios yeah cuz you
only originally asked for was at 175
seventy dollars or the q7 okay 75 a
couple weeks maybe you know really and
was the idea with that obviously with a
smaller
as well was the idea with that to then
use that as sort of like like seed money
to like publishers and be like look this
is something people want or no we were
you making a different game yankees game
but it was ever going to be very small
scope we thought if we get that money
the six of us can still make a game baby
a very small scope yeah but when there
when the money went through the roof and
we realized we could we could hire a
proper studio and also like Steve like
you know gets paid such a lot of money
it's merely you know it took all of it
mainly my 15 year old back yeah it's got
new house a whole lot bigger I know and
both of you like design your own shirts
now absolutely yeah well I got to the
Facebook actually pretty good yeah
that's great fan of this is or is it
really yeah when the characters came out
there is such a great great fan art
community for the the characters and you
know when you get that you think yeah
people like the characters when people
are prepared to do the fan art yeah just
like hundreds of pieces of finite it's
amazing so I guess for the folks who
maybe don't know the sort of the
predecessor or the spiritual predecessor
in relation to this talk about your time
working on banjo kazooie like to talk
about what what was that like do you
still remember those days fondly oh yeah
absolutely right that days will never
forget really working together on and
it's an atmosphere we very much tried to
recreate it platonic oh yeah like human
that was in Benghazi was just a team
shouting down the kodo to people and you
know the other nicknames like it's
almost like banjo kazooie until he was
yesterday and right ladies today I guess
there's no but it's just the same ol
Mickey taken it went on back then it's
nothing's different but it's the same
death things are still the same
nicknames the thing is you know it's a
bit boring really so that kind of led
into the game that's what the game why
that kind of funny sarcastic humor thing
going on you know just cuz we're old
that's the way that's we were but we try
to work in the same efficient way so
there's efficient efficient efficient
that's right a specking all that word
yeah so there's little wasted work
because the team is experienced in this
sort of game so yeah allows us as
because 20 people for a gain of this
scope is still quite small so I think
the absolute allows us to a punch above
our weight a little bit so totally I
mean as a kickstarter like it it seemed
like a pretty sound investment because I
don't sound investment but like a pretty
sound punt because I mean you guys are
so experienced in what you're doing
you have that sort of like I don't know
like you're you're you're probably more
experienced as individuals that a lot of
other people would be in this genre
which also is very underserved at the
moment like your are you know in with
some ways some of the only people left
who have ever made you're just so over
so much so a lot of advice to keep going
yeah yeah but for a new studio to whirl
up something like this would have taken
a lot more time and a lot more piece to
a lot of young people this is a new John
because they rightly never paid for you
know free roaming girth open web
platform is so yeah like an animal you
did those games it's a bit like you know
um there was tons of platforms were out
you know but now it's weird to be like
they'll burn out now there's no one this
we like the only guys let out there
right now yeah I mean like when Ben Joe
because the way was a thing but that was
when 3d platformers we're kind of in
their hate oh yeah yeah does that mean
like you know you're making ukulele now
and it's almost like a brand new
audience that you know are you adjusting
or like trying to change things off of
it too yeah yeah yeah yeah we're doing
we're doing new stuff things mainly
around player choice so we've got
expandable worlds where our fully
expanded worlds are so big we start the
play off with a more manageable chunk of
world and then when they've got enough
qualities they can progress to either
expand the world to see a lot more or
they can go straight to the next world
so they've got a choice there or there's
a tonics which are like playing modify
so if you're struggling like challenge
you can boost your powers in a certain
way you don't have to unlock the moves
in the particular order I think we're
trying to attract get that kind of warm
tickling us from the original games and
like bring it up today you know so we
kind of Rebecca joburg for that spirit
in there yeah and adding touchable that
will like better now than we were then
you know there's no guarantees like but
we're hoping that we're I'm about
composer season better our teachers are
likely a gun I mean you know he's he's
struggling a little bit you know but I
mean have you know so hoping that it's a
bit better now than we were then so you
know it's not a retro game it's supposed
to be it's got about that that nice it's
like putting on your favorite pro
slippers it feels nice right you smile
it's this new stuff to you know so yeah
I'm it back in but the 80 town of 80,000
backers are expecting a spiritual
successor to banjos right it's a fine
line we don't stray too far away from
that formula they're expecting but then
again we are bringing in loads of cool
new features as well and then the part
oh my god the cart sequences you got the
car and the fact that it's on you know
current-gen consoles and with the
graphics up that makes it fresh straight
away cuz ya genre that just it just
doesn't pin around for so long totally
and I feel like this is the one of those
genres that a lot of people have trouble
nailing the art style for it yeah it's
just our natural art style being part of
rare and now pay tonic it's just the art
store that comes naturally tours and I
think that will be played on its art
style going forward he knows you yeah a
one-trick pony springs to mind really
it's a good trick you might as well
stick with that alright well I mean
you're going back to your old trader all
right yes all rights to mr. 52 yes be
the same old jokes definitely how are
you going to manage that one grand like
trying to obviously like instill the
classic music that people no no you know
your work so fondly well you know I've
got some Palestinian think you know but
that's a bit left over from LA before so
just chillin out you know I think I
think we we have been really kind of am
congressman not to just it would be C be
an autopilot right just kind of do the
same thing before right really careful
not to do that and we're pushing each
other to say I think I could be better
than that and you know musically and all
that stuff for all the travel you have
to make it extra special yeah you know
so am we're trying our best so and I
guess the other thing about like having
such success on on kickstarter and and
it like there seems to be like this
general air of like there's no worry
with this one it seems that we usually
with like very like yeah I come together
I that this one seems like it's like
it's pretty solid so then I you know you
it's like a second lease of life for you
guys again back to get X yeah I Thomas
now you're thinking like that when you
when you walk into the office and you
see all these old faces from the past
old yeah that you maybe haven't worked
with since like 20 years ago right
sometimes it's like some kind of strange
alternate reality and I have to pinch
yourself this is really happening so
it's been a really sort of sort of set
of thought your disasters that have kind
of got its back together again really
because some of the guys got laid off
from rasim yeah as left rare so it's the
first time since bunch of two that we're
all available really right so it's been
that kind of strange alarm at the stars
so it's kind of happened a really great
time I guess we've talked about this
a little bit before yes but kudos to
gavin price or studio head he was the
one he brought us all together raelians
at come on lad so you know I think we
can do this yeah yeah him in his white
even his wife at a cake shop in
burton-on-trent is that what he did
afterwards well yeah bet the sense i was
working at rare that was okay she's used
to kind of getting business loans or
black was lot like all right so he was
like she was like i don't have to do
this you just that you just make music
random oh he was like i'll put it
together don't worry I'll sort of the
business so far and you can just guys
can just do it so I think it took him to
do it really is a catalyst right for the
cake experience has been very valuable
it's great did it still make the cakes I
think the opposite of EA's wife made the
case I thought yer so I thought you sold
the cake shop it's old vacation because
it cakes tho yeah I think I'm okay yeah
makes it hard still cakes going on there
it's a lot of cake each when are we
going to get to play ukulele well
backers will play at first because
there's the the toy box which is coming
out next month yeah once it was a
certain tier 4 kickstart it's a
spoiler-free special level that's been
created there's there's things to do on
there there's a new MPC to me there's
quills to collect you can try all the
moves play plates can give us feedback
yeah that's great different people from
yeah that helps to balance it all
certainly and makes them feel them go
yeah yeah yeah I people can't buy into
that now right no that was a backer
exclusive and then yeah that it's a
first-quarter 2017 awesome we're looking
forward to it thank you both so much for
come on I've one random question all
right though grand last one up I was
looking through your Wikipedia page
chart white long right you know I don't
know how much duplication happened in
that with the booze day but it's quite
long it's really good right and one of
the games i saw in there was fart cash
podcast yeah which part cat which is an
iOS game it was made like then carrello
right and rich gallop we used to do my
job that's right this John Ellis guys oh
yeah you know those guys yeah cuz like i
used to work at a 36 a check you worked
his 38 ohs I think the Tamil all right
sir ice select so I knew those guys were
I went bust yes SAR cap was there their
next venture which of course didn't go
so well off and you know but you know
it's notorious obviously yeah yeah
that's great I'd heard you'd for that
one it's quite far see obviously yes
yeah congratulations guys on your
successful day Thank accelerates amazon
not at all looking forward to planar
there
already next year you're watching the
game spot stage brought to you by
airheads bites